i actually think being lazy is a good  thing what because i think if you're  lazy you're actually giving yourself an  indication that you don't like it i am  lazy around housework school i hate it  quote-unquote laziness can have a more  thoughtful conversation of is it  laziness or are you showing yourself  that you don't like that thing and it  becomes a mechanism to self-awareness i  think we need to stop apologizing for  being lazy all of us and we need to use  it as an indicator of i don't like that  thing this job this relationship this  school this startup and then use it as a  starting point to try something else on  the side that eventually can become your  thing and you can stop doing that thing  that you're quote-unquote lazy